in regards to subordinate leadership how
do you begin to change the culture /
school of thought of an industry or a
company you know I'm not sure if they
mean in regards to how do you change
your subordinate leadership's or if you
are subordinate I'm not sure what which
one of those it is but regardless
doesn't matter because guess what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna lead that's what I'm
gonna do
whether I'm on whether I'm the
subordinate guy or the superior guy I'm
gonna lead mmm oh we're gonna I want to
change things and make them a certain
way cool I'm gonna do those things I'm
gonna make those things happen that's
how you do it and if you're doing the
right things for the right reasons your
message is going to spread yeah
you know how many bad seagull platoons I
was in I'm in zero you know why cuz me
and my buddies we always had a good
attitude we always had the right
attitude and that spread to the other
people that were with us now there's a
red flag that you can get for yourself
and this is frustration when you start
saying yourself which I'm not saying
this necessarily but this kind of
question is coming from somebody that
wants change to happen but it's not
happening so they're getting frustrated
and they're thinking they aren't on
board or they don't care and they aren't
professional they're not motivated like
me they don't have a good attitude to
you there's a lot of blame going on
right there you know so this isn't about
them though it's about you and it's
about leading from any level in the
chain of command if you're leading if
you're doing the right things for the
right reasons that's gonna spread so
when the classic example I talked about
at all time is if you're exercising
extreme ownership if you're saying you
know what I got this there was a mistake
made it was my fault that spreads yeah
if your humble that spreads if you have
an open mind that spreads if you're
being aggressive not again not
aggressive towards other people but if
you're being aggressive in pursuit of
your goal that spreads mm-hmm you know
what doesn't spread is when you're
aggressive at people mm-hmm oh oh
actually it does spread but it's
negative yeah you know it doesn't spread
it doesn't spread when you're trying to
get people to do things because it's
gonna make you look good yeah that
doesn't spread mm-hmm you can't get
people to behave better because you want
to look good it doesn't work yeah people
see right through that oh he wants to
look good you know what I'm gonna do
sabotage now the other thing I've been
saying lately because people are
surprised or whatever or not surprised
but they're concerned they don't see how
it's gonna work so fast and I say you
know what it's not gonna work fast it's
gotta be and here's the word it's got to
be a campaign it's got to be a campaign
it's not like World War two was not one
battle World War one was not one battle
it's a campaign to win in Europe it's a
campaign to win in the Pacific it takes
battle after battle after battle and
guess what you don't win them all yeah
you lose some of them and so you're
gonna on this campaign you're gonna win
and you're gonna lose but you gotta have
the persistence and the patience and the
persuasiveness to continue and another
piece of this is you are best off if you
go in direct and not be like hey you
need to act like me no people don't like
that you need to just act how you're
acting and if you're doing it like I
said the right things for the right
reasons people are gonna see you and
they're gonna follow
so that's how you begin to change the
school of thought yeah that genuineness
like tends to show itself or that like
if you're not genuine it tends to show
itself you know just because the
dynamics of Vinnie that's mine tends to
it just straight shows so when you're
doing it for the right reasons like you
you can't help but expose that you know
that will be exposed so yeah people will
sign on a sign right on and then you end
up gaining like how you say it's a
campaign it's like you'll gain a little
bit of ground you might win this guy
over like hey wait that's a you know
that's a cool way of doing it or
whatever the group is and you make these
small little steps you kind of hold that
ground and yeah before you know it it's
kind of dang the whole culture of this I
don't know office or whatever mm-hmm
it's kind of changing you know I just